women this is why your country because
you use your women for this these are
the al jazeera pictures causing outrage
across the united states
desperate and hungry haitian migrants
trying to make it back to a makeshift
camp with food and water met by force
the men on horseback work for department
of homeland security secretary alejandro
maracas who promised in the senate
hearing tuesday there will be
consequences i directed that the office
of professional responsibility be
present on site in del rio 24 7 to
ensure that the conduct of our personnel
adheres to our policies
to our policies to our training and to
our values i was horrified to see the
images and we look forward to learning
the facts that are reduced from the
investigation
the u.s vice president also weighed in
what i saw depicted
about um those individuals on horseback
treating human beings the way they were
horrible
but republicans in congress are making a
broader political point saying border
security is broken and president biden
is to blame
all i can say is mr secretary is that
sooner or later this administration is
going to have to take responsibility for
the crisis that you have fomented at the
border that gets worse day upon day but
for the thousands of haitians who hoped
this would be their first step to a new
life in america they are now being moved
to other processing centers and are
expected to be flown back to haiti in
the next 10 days
the biden administration is continuing
the policy set up by the trump
administration which says because of the
pandemic they can deport people right
away without even giving them a chance
to ask for asylum now that has angered
many in the president's own party but so
far it doesn't appear that the bite
administration plans to change that
policy and if it does it would likely
come too late for the thousands of
haitians on the border
patti calhane al jazeera washington